Heather's gonna start us off in Florida
hi Heather what's up in your world hi
Dave I started the Total Money Makeover
about ten or twelve years ago Wow and
there was a book on tape in my car on a
car ride to visit my sister in North
Carolina and to this day right now is
I'm actually just paid off my house in
December later the house is gone yeah
thank you and I have quite a good quite
a good stash in my 403b and my Roth IRA
but I was actually unfortunately I had
to leave my husband in December due to
domestic violence but I'm super grateful
that I was able to leave him financially
because it wasn't a good situation for
me and my kids and I just I have you to
thank for that to be able to sorry I
told myself I wasn't gonna cry oh you
get you got control of your life and I
gave you choices I'm proud of you yeah
yeah when I had like you had to make a
difficult one you were able to Wow yeah
yeah and I'm still doing the best I can
I'm staying out of debt and the only
thing that'll put me back in that is
unfortunately probably lawyer bills but
hopefully I can get ahead of that but I
am really really really grateful for all
your advice and your help and it
definitely was a hard decision to make
as you can imagine so yeah how old are
you 37 you know paid for house yeah
actually renting it out right now so I
haven't paid for it I'm renting it so
making income on it 100% so very cool
yeah well good for you
very proud of you well done well done
okay so there's a lady out there
listening right now maybe to the show
instead of a book on tape yeah she's
just thinking about maybe trying this
stuff what do you tell her because you
did it yeah
snowball and all that and I mean it's
definitely hard to get started but once
you get going it's SuperDuper easy to
pack your lunch everyday and not eat
Starbucks or drink Starbucks coffee like
coffee from the Keurig is really good so
I definitely you know definitely make
that jump because you'll be thankful in
10 to 12 years from now so and I've
encouraged a lot of other people in my
work I've done your smart dollar program
like for my employees and stuff so
brought this to other people and I've
had a lot of really good successes from
it and one of my best friends that see
you Shiva they're really good obviously
listening right now and see paid off
about thirty thousand dollars in debt in
two years by doing it as well right not
a lot of grateful people so thank you
well thank you well done very proud of
you miss Heather so Heather can I ask
you this question yes is it why you
called that a bit but you got me on the
phone now so I want to pick you back off
Dave's question so you've got a mom
who's sitting at home right now who's
finding herself a situation where her
husband sucks and is not treating her
the dignity that she deserves
he's hitting her yeah yeah what do you
tell that mom save your money in cash
and definitely make a plan to get out
there's act I participated in the active
treatment program it's abuse counseling
treatment is very very helpful and
informative and make a plan have a
safety plan and definitely get out
because you don't want your kids to live
that life and repeat that for future
generations do it for your kids if you
can't do it for yourself because most
mom can you are a courageous powerful
extraordinary woman Heather and I'm I'm
grateful to have got to talk to you
today yeah what a gift pretty incredible
pretty incredible well done well done
mmm you know I
you've worked around that disastrous
situation and so of ah sadly and it's if
you have not been in that situation it
is difficult to understand how much it
took for her to go from the
list of low spirits and the lowest of
low self-esteem because it steals your
spirit in your self-esteem it takes
everything down right it just rings you
out up to where she is hmm I mean that's
up the distance Jesus traveled in
raising herself up and and in walking
you know through that program and
welcome to friends welcome with God to
be able to find the courage to get out
because you you begin to believe you
your deserve it you're worthless right
yeah you're worthless and you're stuck
and all of that and like she said make a
plan get out because otherwise it will
be it's high probability of a being
generational high probability